[Music]
did you guys used to download uh
absolutely mp3s yeah never
you never did that honestly dude
i'm sorry i followed the law
you're a loser dude charters the law i
would go to tower records and buy an
album
oh you guys don't support artists no
we're i paid for their concerts
that's pretty we never survived we never
supported what was the first app you
guys used to do that kazaa napster i
used limelight my very first was you go
into aol chat rooms and then they give
you private chat yeah and then there
would be guys running bots right and i
used to run boxes like yeah you could be
like slack because we do you guys are
all going to jail and you could do like
slash search in the chat room you could
be like slash say list me back for babe
uh baby bash
whatever right and then and then the
chat room bro the guy goes are you
[ __ ] kidding me he's like give me all
the baby back you guys would give you a
list of songs or whatever and be like
send boys to men send whatever and then
they would just start bombing that [ __ ]
in your email and then you just start
downloading them i remember that that
was the very first that was the very
first one for me yeah because when i was
running listserv what you do is you
leave
all these uh music files in your inbox
in your actual like aol mailbox and what
it is is when you run the bot people say
you they get the list and they say send
116 it'll send email 116 and forward it
to them
so it just it just bounces [ __ ] out and
as long as the bots running your things
auto email you're so [ __ ] advanced at
the time what was that what was the
biggest thing though napster that was
the first thing that i think was the
first biggest yeah the big one then it
was like uh limewire
was uh lightweight lasted a really long
time because i'll light yeah because i
like it and then i got a care bear or
something to a guy
remember
the whole torrents at a time
video games movies i was just acting
like an angel before i definitely did it
now he's like the pro
i'm neo
so yeah limewire did start uh may 2000
and it ended 2010 so it was up for 10
years
and now it's making a comeback let's go
i heard limewire but it is being
resurrected under a different form it is
going to become an nft marketplace wow
limewire nfc marketplace i don't know it
even existed
is it also for pirated nf teens
they're just like oh i get it right
click save limewire
an amazing twist you'll be hilarious you
guys remember napster yeah yeah justin
timberlake was the owner of lobster yeah
yeah the criminal
and uh well because of the movie but
then like limewire yeah yeah yeah
[Laughter]
remember nasa i'm like we just mentioned
that like four minutes ago yeah
[Laughter]
i wasn't here for that conversation
sorry guys
live water is coming back as an nft
marketplace you could buy nfts using usd
and uh yeah that's gonna be their new
image
they're putting all the pirating behind
them nft nft viruses like half of
limewire back in the day oh yeah
limewire did have tons of viruses so
that's why i don't know if the reason
but mac started getting hella popular
with all my homies because you're way
less likely to get yeah that's so all
the videos like i'm definitely getting
back next time i'm like all right bro
well mcafee was stealing money from
everyone yeah yeah because most of the
viruses weren't compatible with it what
came in after limewire kazar
yeah yeah yeah there was a lot of
different and then streaming stuff i
think started to pop like pandora around
that similar era pandora was free it was
kind of dope i remember when pandora's
next level do pandora's uh song matching
like with genre was so good it wasn't
especially compared to now i listen to
spotify now dude they still play the
same song regardless of what channel you
choose yeah after a while they play the
same thing like oh that's crazy big
sean's on again yeah yeah yeah yeah
and i put more like linda ronstadt and
got big sean yeah kinda pandora's still
pretty good yeah i still use it you're
listening to norah jones and then big
sean popped out
damn dude big sean's everywhere man
i'm not like a business guru or nothing
but if i'm limewire
which now in hindsight everyone jokes
about being illegal
why wouldn't you just switch your name
and start a nft spot
because i actually i think that using
something that has notoriety regardless
is stronger than starting from scratch
especially in the kind of very like uh
early adoption phase
and
it's our demographic i guess you're
right our age group and that's why
you're not a business guru that's why i
admitted it i threw it over to anthony
this guy knows how to make money i'm
just following it
i'm just trying to catch up
limewire along with napster and all
those apps those were like the people's
chat back when these same people who
were buying and selling nfts were kids
or teens
like you have fond memories like no one
has bad memories of that stuff other
than the virus you'd get but that's some
random dick popping up some ads only
metabolism
still pretty good yeah the regular
person likes lamb lime one separate yeah
metallica they were so it was so funny
they would have like music conventions
and they were so [ __ ] against this
[ __ ] oh yeah they're so so angry
they lost their street cred yeah they
were trying to fight like mcdonald's
and then there were also actual people
that got heavily sued for downloading
music and they tried to make examples
out of it yeah did any of you guys get
in trouble i had a friend i got a
warning i remember but i think he was
just straight downloaded movie after
movie after that
i also remember like kids in college
dorms started getting hit that was my
buddy because they're ip address it's
like it's connected to your room so i'm
like [ __ ] this [ __ ] t1 is fast as
[ __ ] no but i can't download anything
dude we used to get letters from the
charter company like the the cable uh
internet company they would tell you
like hey stop downloading illegal
tournaments
like what are you doing i got that i got
that like twice yeah what were you doing
i was downloading movies i was down in
like old bruce lee movies i was
downloading like game of death
i was downloading everything right back
anything that i liked i was just trying
to look forward to downloading porn
because back then it was hard to stream
oh yeah porn was the greatest my friend
had a terabyte of porn dude back then i
was like damn right back then what the
[ __ ] was that even on that's because
they didn't compress well oh yeah that's
true
so even like one photo was like
megabytes that's a good point no he just
had his [ __ ] downloading non-stop and he
just had a terabyte of that [ __ ] and i'm
like why
and he goes you want to borrow it i'm
like yeah
let me see that's why okay i remember
hard drives were like this and you need
the usb connector and you have to plug
it in yeah electric cord two cars that's
right into the power source right that
was crazy
terrified yeah now it's like all in one
and this one thing it's crazy sleek and
[ __ ] yeah
yeah i think that's a pretty cool move
for them because uh
so far they're the first to do that as
far as the old apps like all of them are
just buried gone where yeah it would
come back anyway soul seek is actually
still around i don't know if you guys
soul seek soul seek is just like this
but it was uh it was peer-to-peer same
thing it's still operating exactly the
same way today never changed oh send me
a link nft peer-to-peer similar concept
maybe that's oh isn't it i mean nft oh
for blockchain yeah it's it's like the
concept oh yeah landmarks you're
downloading from someone else who has it
right maybe that's why they kept the
names yes yeah the back end software is
maybe similar true you interested
absolutely you're an nft guy what do you
think
i love all pirated things it's not
pirated is illegal oh i'm sorry um yes
interesting here's the new word for it i
love all open sourced things
open source i i always appreciate
peer-to-peer things except uh over the
uh over like some sort of centralized
exchange of some sort you know what i
mean because second like you put a
middleman is the second the money and
the fees uh get changed but every single
time it's peer-to-peer it's it's the
fastest it's the cheapest it's the most
trusted sometimes maybe when you see
when you see like another open source
kinder t-shirt walking around you're
like that's what i like we didn't make
it someone else did it's the most
trusted
peer-to-peer that's why peer-to-peer
makes sense because if somebody has it
and they didn't get it from you they got
it from somebody who got it from me it's
different all right fine
there's a bunch of fake kid just
t-shirts all over the internet like just
really these random companies making
them yeah crank them out we just we just
started our season assist a couple like
a couple years ago like i was getting
targeted ads from fake cages merch and i
was like hey is this real he was like
huh is this real and then i had to like
literally send it to my arlo because i
was like what the [ __ ] that's open
source man that's messed up no that's
that's right click save
you notice that you're literally taking
it's not like we put our uh our [ __ ]
ai file out there it was just their logo
on like a yellow shirt which i've never
seen any of them wear it was like
misspelled too yeah but the idea of him
looking
that's what i like
ah piracy ah alibaba just peered up here
man
[Laughter]
it's so
cool i will say the first song that
happened though a small part of me is
like oh we made it yeah yeah
that's true
afterwards i was like all right stop
also it doesn't look good so there's
that
i remember uh one time me and bart did a
meet and greet on the east coast and in
the audience there were these two fans
that were like hey
yo bar and i'm like those look those
shirts look familiar and then i look
close and i'm like that's our shirts but
that's not ours and i was like and then
when it came up i was like where did you
get that like oh we didn't have time to
buy your shirts and get it on time so
what we did is we got the design from
your website and then we printed it and
then we wanted to come support
oh that's kind of
cute if they don't sell it
i thought it was weird it is a weird
vibe
wait
that's the first one that comes up when
you search kenji's shirt is that stolen
oh that but that's that's not uh that's
somebody's reselling it so someone's
selling it on ebay yeah reselling is
fine you can't stop that yeah no that's
kind of dope yeah that's fine what about
when you see yourself if they're like a
manufacturer and they're like you know
selling mass quantity and then it's like
the [ __ ] then that's what you really
like huh
that's capitalism baby this one's gotta
be real the one on the top are you
searching all this [ __ ] right now
no because this is a good deal it's on
wish.com that's the one that's hella
fake
meister or not let me see this [ __ ] hold
on
[ __ ] it now you gotta send me these
links and send
oratee yeah
i'm going to go to wish.com i'm going to
buy i'm going to buy this dude
[Music]
buy him out anthony
hey check out the new bruh
what do you think
the dude at work man look at that doing
business cease and desist right now this
is baby [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
you